in the marriage of heaven and hell blake  articulated his critique of swedenborg  indeed the very title  marriage of heaven and hell encapsulated  his sense that these were not  too radically dichotomous in distinct  locations  problem he noted was that he'd conversed  only with angels  and not with the devils who hated  religion  he'd had the wrong informants  you want to know what hell it's like you  got to talk to a devil i mean it's  it's perfectly obvious what swedenborg  had failed to see  blake noted his annotations to  swedenborg was that heaven and hell  are born together  he articulated a notion of dynamic  oppositions  what is basic is a series of countries  attraction and repulsion reason and  energy  love and hate and these oppositions were  necessary for life  what religions called good and evil were  secondary terms  derivatives which sprang from these  basic series of countries  they were not primary